[Music]
[Applause]
he's sir nick faldo cbs sports lead golf
analyst joining us from home after
spending the weekend at augusta
i was wondering about the
going into this tournament everybody
talked about tiger and and the terrain
there at augusta
you know those kind of majors are
draining anyway as you know but yeah how
much do you think it was the stress of
trying to compete in the masters as
opposed to the physical part of trying
to compete in the masters
no i think it was the physical yeah it
was
um that's what i was talking about
obviously he
you know he lives in florida plays in
florida he played the father and son
when he walked came on and off his cart
which i thought was impressive because
you know
he was spending uh you know a long time
wasn't like like he was disappearing he
would stay on on the range to watch his
son hit balls so i thought that was a
good sign but then then he talked about
you know getting the flexion of the foot
i mean that was and obviously
it's the toughest walk especially the
downhill i mean you if you're fit and
healthy you'll get shin splints that
week
you really will
and
so anyway bottom line i i didn't
i would have i would have gone there for
like maybe 36 holes and done a real
route march and
boot camp and see if i can survive it
but i think he was secretly so i spoke
to him at champions dinner and he was uh
should have been working on the beach
which making on a soft sound which makes
sense because your foot really has to
move back and you'll get you'll really
get up some stress factor or
some
just stress you know you're tested the
your um
you know
your motion as well as stamina you know
that's that's a real important thing but
you know i think considering
i was i was so impressed with it i mean
he's
again i spoke to him and said so what's
your pain level one to ten and he went
way higher i went wow really he said is
it more than oh eight he saw playing on
a broken leg was nothing
compared to this you know and he's in 24
7 pain so you can imagine sleep and
everything and that sort of so
i thought to do that would give him huge
hope that wow i can basically walk any
golf course now
and we played he played all right you
know it's interesting i'm just reading
his own quotes about the putting on
dates well day three day four
i think he was in he was in pain
addressing the putt so i think i guess
he was moving around trying to get rid
of that and that affected the stroke and
everything and that's why
uh he missed a lot of putts so
if he can and i've just heard his he's
committed
to san andreas right now
so that's that's i mean it's bottom line
that's all fantastic isn't it i mean and
i'm sure it's given him huge hope to
think
you know and the other thing he get
again in your mid forces whether you've
been injured or not
just sustaining your mobility through
the day you know as we get older once
your hips get tight and your shoulders
get tight the swing doesn't you know and
he had he was able to keep that fluidity
through the swing throughout the day
so i
he wanted a better result but i you know
the physical test i think he
i think he did brilliantly
and saint andrews is perfect for him
because that's flat
well yeah compared to ghastly yeah i
mean obviously you get a lot of twisting
and this sort of thing yeah
but you don't get long the long climbs
up my goodness there's there's a half a
dozen holes which are uh yeah heart
attack heels up out there as you
wouldn't get a bit older well i pointed
out that eight is straight up the hill
yeah i mean nine is straight down 10
straight down then you go back up i mean
it's yeah
absolutely now you're absolutely right
you climb up and with that leg walking
down six i mean six is like this off the
tee
um
you know
yeah all the way it's so and obviously
up at the last few as well up 17 and 18.
so i think that as i said the
physical he can do it must be he must
feel really good the right if he knows
how to look after it
and
then he knows how to prepare
how is life going to change for scotty
sheppler to win a major at 25.
well i hear i mean i know him a little
bit
but
gleaning from other people
is not going to change this is probably
the most level
you know easygoing guy out there i mean
stardom is like
so what i'm a girlfriend obviously he's
going to make fortunes and they said hey
sure it's coming to mad rush it's a bit
like a i mean it's a bit like the you
know the uh the pop stars you've you're
a nobody and then you get a an album
that goes
crazy and then sure in four months
it's like i went from
you know
playing golf you know you know in a van
and now i can afford anything so hey he
might
that may change or whatever who knows
but as
as what i'm hearing from people and i i
chat to him a little bit
um
he's a real down-to-earth guy
yeah and there's
you know i know he was a great junior
golfer and he was a pretty good college
golfer but
what stands out like there's nothing
that you go wow with scottie scheffler
other than when he needed to have a shot
make a shot make a putt yeah he did it
which i don't know how you
quantify that
but
what what is special about scottie
scheffler
well he delivers really well i mean he
i'm his
he's a scrambling man he spent you know
one of his as a kid he's just prac bit
like jordan speed very similar when
jordan spieth was literally unbeatable
great scrambler so he's got maze and his
ability to just see the right shot play
the right shots um
[Music]
was was fantastic i mean those
you cannot appreciate
the severity of
the pitch shots at augusta
um hey the shot is difficult and you
know in the backyard
right in the front of your mind you know
if it goes wrong
that golf ball goes off for wandering it
goes off 30 40 feet away and uh
and then that's another
another serious challenge from there so
um
just fantastic with how many the drivers
it's very interesting you know he
really struggles in the draw but he's
going to with his foot action you know
his feet leaping back and you know weak
grip
so i was trying to express that say how
difficult that was but but if you can
find a way to keep that fade going all
day long which he just about did
um
and
you know and he's got great when you're
playing great
i do remember that from moons ago you
have such a wonderful you do have such a
wonderful clear vision you just look at
the flag and all you're concentrating on
is how do i get it close to the flag i
mean how do i work the ball to get it
closed sure you see all the hazards but
they're kind of like a bit of a blur you
know you know they're there you register
but your focus is so darn good and of
course when you hit a few sideways
doesn't take many in our game then you
suddenly ah all the hazards are all
crisp in focus and the flags are blur
you know you think how the heck do i get
it close so
um he's in that wonderful mode where
he's just hey
there's my target poof and i hit it at
it great sir nick faldo cbs sports lead
golf analyst um
the uh
spoiler alert before rory hit the bunker
shot
um
you got roughed up a little bit on
social media there nick i yeah i did i
mean that was uh
i know it was a rookie mistake but you
know i'm sitting there right in there
and i
and it just happened and it was just off
the charts
and so jim's talking to me and asking me
a question and i know and so
my and when you hear
the
the patrons raw the crowd go nuts
you can't come back and go let's look at
rory live out of the bunker at 18.
because you you know it's on it's now on
tape a split second
and i just um i got caught up in that
for that split second and i said you
know i
and i
reacted
and so yeah you're right i got i got it
all wrong for a split second
i seriously was shaking because i
thought roy's going to win the greek i
thought something could happen you know
he's trying to we know the story
and
and he pulls off an impossible shot
and
his reaction and i'm sitting right in
the middle of it so i'm sorry i i
blurted
you know i didn't actually say what
happened i said oh my god so you know
you won't believe what's happening or
something so yeah spoiler alert but
hey i guess rookie mistake but
gosh when you're in it like i mean
you can tell i love it i mean i'm right
in the mid mix of it literally
and then he pulls off that and i
obviously thought for a second because
anything could happen if he post i kept
saying all day if rory could post yeah
no 8 under
and um
you know and
he could have won i mean you it's very
easy for scotty to hit in the trees and
be you know be stymied behind the tree
and has to chip out and makes a mess
so
um
yeah
as you know you're up there doing live
golf i've been up there for
18 odd years now so that was my first
first cock-up well you also have when
you're when you're at augusta and you
hear the roars
that we know if we're watching you know
the 10th green
yeah so you know something something
just happened and then you're going to
go to it then you have to act like you
didn't know what happened that's well
that's what i agree i'm we we are we're
in this world with television where we i
feel you have to be truthful you can't
cut to something
and if somebody's chipped in
and you know it's going in
you know that's
you
i like we i mean sellers shy our
producer they do they do an unbelievable
job to show us
live golf but obviously when
great when you're following it's not
like we're we are such a difficult sport
because we're not following one ball are
we or anything we've got one guy putting
for whatever for the lead and there's
probably three other guys putting or
chipping on other holes
at the exact same time so they
something's going to go on tape and it
has to but how many monitors do you get
to see when you're with no i don't see
no i don't i see what you see i see what
i don't i have nothing i have no
heads up
on anything i call exactly what you see
at television at home i have one monitor
that's it so we get fed in our ear going
to 14 or going to da da and buff up pops
a picture and off we go so but you're on
18 so you saw rory right in front of you
yeah it's exactly i'm sitting at 18 and
right there and i'm up in my little
tower and rory is down there and so i
just peep out and you go in i've got jim
talking in one ear and daddy and that
happens i'm like
holy crap you won't believe me
so
yeah so all the knuckleheads gave me a
a rough ride but you know
as we say they um
you know
their mums are probably saying to me are
you still up
i told you to go to bed
uh it's always great to talk to you um
when's your next event
oh next week well this week i'm up at
hilton head oh okay yeah that's right
yeah yeah so we're we're back in the
saddle again uh at least hilton has a
lovely chill you know it's nice get a
little get a little condominium by the
harbor and i can watch the
rich and famous go by in their boats and
that sort of thing you know
so yeah it's just it's a nice yeah i
gotta go i need a i need a i need a
deep de-stressing day today the puppies
are hopefully coming soon so they get a
lot of love so that's that'll be my day
and i'm packing and that you know
all the usual but you're allowed to say
crowd now and fans now you you now you
can go back to normal
go go yes go back
to yes rowdy whatever they are yeah
you know unwatched all those sorts of
things yeah uh well safe travels and uh
thanks as always nick we appreciate it
all right good to talk to you
sir nick faldo cbs sports lead golf
analyst